[Music]
kelsey is with us in baltimore maryland
kelsey how can george campbell and i
help
hi guys i'm so excited to be talking to
you you too um
so i have a question about whole life
insurance um my parents got a policy for
me when i was
in the crib and um passed this policy on
to me a few years ago um we used we took
a loan out from it um to put down on the
house and
you know just kind of knowing we never
had to pay it back
and
just knowing that i didn't really care
about this policy it's very small we
have other life insurance that's not
whole
um
i'm not sure what to do on you know to
keep it active i'd pay about
800 900 a year
um and
really cancel
what about the tax implications don't
worry about that at all there aren't any
oh here's why okay your tax basis
in a whole life policy is the total of
the premiums paid in
there is no possible way
that you took out of this policy more
than your parents has paid in
yeah they're just they're just horrible
it's it's a black hole for money
especially kid whole life policies your
parents meant well they were really
sweet and the net result was they were
able to help you with the down payment
on a house had they actually invested in
the mutual fund with the same amount of
money they put in this policy they could
have just bought you a house but that's
a side issue
that's open that's water under the
bridge now so that's how bad these
things are mathematically so but anyway
yeah you don't keep it around no it's
not a pet and
we can honor their intent and their
heart without uh you know continuing to
throw money
off the bridge every day every month
every year right
so yeah i would just
if you don't need the life insurance i
just cancel it
um if the basis does come in and they
will send it to you because they'll
threaten you with this it's their way of
getting you to not cancel it apparently
that's already happened that's where you
got this information
the agent says oh no you're going to get
taxed and you're like yeah it's four
dollars you know but uh uh instead of
800 this year so i i can i
i'm going to give you a 95
probability that there's no taxes on it
at all
on the five percent chance that there is
their your taxes will be less than your
premium this year
okay so i mean at the end of the day
when you get get it all done it's not
gonna you're because you're again your
basis
is the total of the premiums paid in
and only if you receive more than that
including the loan amount okay because
the loan is
is paid off as a part of the uh the
cancellation and if there's anything
above the loan that comes to you those
two things if that is larger than the
total of the premiums only then will
there be taxes and it almost never is
because these things really suck so bad
okay okay great thank you so much steve
thank you for the call
appreciate you joining us you know so
that is like a
product from the 1940s and 1950s it's
like a uh
it's like an alligator it's a dinosaur
that has survived into the modern era
how do they do that
marketing it's a dinosaur because
when you sell it people buy it whatever
it is if you sell it enough aggressively
enough people buy it um i mean gerber
the baby food company still sells whole
life policies wow to people when they
get a baby
so that they can go to college well let
me tell you where you're going to
college
nowhere
not with that you're not getting in
anywhere with that policy yeah okay
because you're going to make 14 when
it's all over you're getting screwed
no listen if you buy your financial
products from a baby food company it
might be doing it wrong
okay if your baby food says
american funds on the outside of it you
might have the wrong baby food come on
don't eat it stay in your lane people
stay in your lane and you talk about why
this is a bad product it's trying to do
two things at once it's trying to be
insurance and an investment and you're
saying hey there's way better ways to
always only one and you're always paying
for both yep
that's the problem so we recommend uh
term life insurance level term life 15
to 20-year policy to where you're
self-insured when that policy runs out
and that's for adults
it's for adults yeah and if you want to
save money for your kids save money for
your kids but there's no need for a
mutual fund a life insurance policy
insurance policy on a kid because if
they pass away you didn't lose their
income now if they get a two million
dollar uh ad campaign contract with
huggies because they have a cute butt
that's great then sign up a life
insurance policy because now you have an
income there for this cute butt and
you've got to take you know you got to
protect that but that's
99 of the children do not make a income
that's worth insuring okay so you know
this is just and so it's being used as a
savings vehicle for college and that's a
freaking joke
so what happened was her parents paid
into it their whole her whole life 20
years and she got five or ten grand out
of it it's the sunk cost fallacy i got
to keep this thing alive because we've
been keeping it alive forever yeah it's
the sacred cow we've always done it this
way and this is why we will always
continue to do it this way we have no
other reasoning
that's it the bad reason it's a sacred
cow rule yeah